joining me now Congressman Jim Comer
chairman of the house oversight
committee Congressman your reaction to
everything that's swirling around
tonight
um what happened today at the courthouse
in Miami and uh you heard the Crickets
they didn't cover anything about the
tape recordings it's a sad day the
history of our country if you look at
what they're charging Donald Trump for
and what we on the house oversight
committee have already brought out on
the Biden family creating 20 shell
companies to launder money through six
American Banks to nine Biden family
members from foreign Nationals in China
and Romania and now we're just now
getting to the bank records on Russia
and Ukraine and yet the media won't
cover anything about Joe Biden or the
fact that he could potentially be
compromised if in fact he has been
recorded except in a bribe from a
foreign National well we have China and
Ukraine that's all I mean they're not
big stories right now and both countries
could very well be involved in the
scheme could it not could they not be
they could be that's why we've been
investigating this from day one we fear
that this President is compromised and
we have the facts to back that up the
facts that his family has taken millions
and millions of dollars from foreign
Nationals in some of the worst countries
on our planet and we have no idea what
the family did to earn that money what
thing of value was provided to those
foreign Nationals to compensate the
bidens for receiving tens of millions we
don't believe that the president's son
or brother had the ability to produce
anything of that magnitude in value we
believe and we fear that this President
did oh you don't trust their financial
Acumen to be bringing their own value to
the table separate from Joe Biden no
I've seen their bank records it's really
bad yeah um now Trump tonight said uh
various things about the prosecution and
the timing of this case
it's also no coincidence that these
charges against me came down the very
same day
evidence revealed Joe Biden took a 5
million dollar bribe from Ukraine took a
five million dollar abroad
but the FBI and the justice department
don't even want to talk about it
well Congressman he's uh he's saying
basically what we just said but it I
mean it really is giving people a sense
of two levels of justice and the scales
are not equally weighted No One Believes
this was a coincidence that on the same
day the FBI produced a document that
showed they've been sitting on
allegations of abiding bribery for years
that uh Donald Trump just happened to be
indicted by the special counsel for for
mishandling a classified doctor between
Joe Biden himself mishandled classified
documents on a much greater scale than
what Donald Trump did and we haven't
heard a thing from that special counsel
where are those tapes
well according to the FBI Forum the
oligarch told the informant that he kept
those tapes as an insurance policy
for giving the bidens a bribe in hopes
that they would produce something of
value in return for the for the millions
of dollars well they did produce
well we we believe that uh firing the
prosecutor in Ukraine was part of the
deal we believe that foreign aid was
part of the deal and if you go back and
look where Joe Biden was during this
time everything fits and look at what
we've produced in Romania less than two
weeks after Joe Biden left Romania
talking about foreign policy and foreign
aid his family started receiving wires
through their shell companies from a
Romanian National while Joe Biden was
vice president none of this is
impeachable though I'm sure now
Congressman you've issued a subpoena to
Devin Archer to appear for a deposition
in this investigation of the Biden
family
um will he show and what do you expect
to learn
I'm confident he will show and Devin
Archer is a is a key person in our
investigation he knew uh very well
exactly what the bidens were doing in
Ukraine and Russia especially he knew
whether or not Joe Biden was involved
and what we want to know from Devin
Archer is what exactly did the bidens do
to receive the millions and millions of
dollars from Russia and Ukraine that
that they received how did they get so
rich I'm going to say this every night
on the show for the next year and a half
how did the bidens get so rich nobody
still nobody's answered that question
nobody they they talk about their
businesses we haven't found that they
have no legitimate businesses that I
have found everything toilet paper art I
mean what's that that he's still getting
money for that lousy art of his by
unknown Bible well that's that's what
he's had to do now that the gig's up on
the influx pedaling he's an artist now
but we don't know who's behind the art
and and you know we're concerned about
that hundreds of thousands of dollars
for crap all right Congress been great
to see you tonight thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else